red flag number 12.
single mothers what's wrong with a
single mother she maybe she just made a
mistake or you know she needs help too
like uh shouldn't we save her
that's what they want you to believe
don't they
um so I have an entire chapter in my
book that deals with single mothers
because I think it's such a difficult
um conversation to have and
I'm speaking from experience because you
know been there done it you know got it
got the T-shirt uh you're in a position
where you essentially choose to cuckold
yourself uh and if you don't know what
that means that means that you're
raising children that aren't
biologically yours the reason why we are
on this Earth today is to scatter our
seed and pass on our DNA our name our
Legacy and all that sort of stuff and if
you choose to abandon an opportunity to
do that to raise another man's seat and
provide for them then you're essentially
a cuck you also have a number of other
issues which are deep in the chapter so
you guys have to read for that but I'll
cover another one is that you have resp
parental responsibility to children that
you have to raise and protect and
provide for and take on vacations and
dinners and birthdays help zero in
little Billy's scope on his BB gun you
do all of these things
but you don't generally have any
authority over them you have
responsibility to them but you don't
have any authority over disciplining
them and if you do try to discipline
them quite often what most guys find
happen is they hear some version of
you're not my father you can't tell me
what to do and they throw a hissy fit
and Mom of course will then side with
the bratty child rather than doing
what's right
yeah you know even with my own children
my wife and I and she makes it a point
to put me ahead of the children and I do
the same thing for her she always her
opinion because she's my teammate in
this but it seems as if when there's
someone else's child involved that child
goes before you as her husband or
whatever
correct
yeah bad deal
um
yeah like you said it's a tough one is
there a lot of guys that find themselves
in this situation and maybe find out a
little too late that this was a bad idea
and you know guys want to protect they
want to provide they want to save but uh
not at the expense of what there was a
there was an ERA where it was shameful
to be a single mother uh if you're a
single mother 500 years ago uh you would
generally be banished or you might even
be forced to work in a brothel you know
for example to sort of you know provide
for your child
um so it was so it was frowned upon
today with culture and Society Hollywood
and media it's like you know it's
celebrated oh you're so strong and brave
you know on Father's day you'll hear
women on social media you know let's
let's praise all those single mothers
because they're doing the jobs of the
mothers and the fathers you know sort of
thing
um and I don't think that it's good for
Society for culture or for the world in
general because
I mean the statistics are very clear
um children that are incarcerated vast
majority of them come from single mother
household children that run away from
home vast majority of several other
households poor great single mother
households uh gang activity uh Teenage
pregnancies I go right down the list uh
the absence of fathers in a household is
a terrible thing for children some guys
might say well then I'll step up and
I'll and I'll take care of it okay well
you can but you've also cocked yourself
now and now you're not raising your own
kids right so
um there's a lot of women out there that
bring children in tow there's a lot of
guys that send me screenshots of dating
apps and like take a look at this rich I
can't believe this is happening and it's
like a 25 year old and her profession is
stay-at-home mom in the description and
she's got three kids from three
different fathers and she's pregnant in
her Bumble advertisement for men and
this is accepted this is normalized you
know
you go girl you're so strong and
independent and Guy and because there's
so many Sims out there they'll swoop in
and they'll they'll sign up for it
you know it's soft as far as you know
the deplorable statistics of the uh the
outcome for children that are raised by
single mothers I read recently that
there are the exact opposite uh
statistics for children that are raised
by a single father correct you're not
interested better
right interesting yeah it's the exact
opposite of what we're told in our you
know in our culture and what the courts
will propose that the child needs a
mother No in fact they fare better with
just the father yeah
crazy
crazy backwards world we live in cool so
red flag number 13. so women seeking
validation what do you mean by that
don't most women seek validation
yeah there's um there's a meme somewhere
where men tend to use things like cell
phones like this where they'll take
pictures of say like cars Landscapes the
Grand Canyon when they're traveling sort
of thing women on the other hand they'll
turn the the camera around they'll do
the selfie so they use their phone for
completely different reasons that's
another strong example of how men and
women are different so women tend to use
social media today to Garner the follows
the likes and the attention of guys for
their whether it's only fans or their
Instagram you know account whatever it
is they're looking for uh but again you
know let's say that you're at the point
where you're dating uh a gal and she
says Elliot I dig your Vibe I want to
claim you I don't want to share you you
should take a good look at her take a
good look at her social media presence
and see what she's been doing with it
and if you find out that she's been
posting photographs of herself sometimes
promiscuous photographs of herself
sometimes they'll even use photographs
that you've taken of her with you cut
out of the photograph or something like
that uh
yeah so you know she's been out there
posting uh uh sexy provocative pictures
of herself an easy response would be
well I like you too but I can't take a
woman seriously if she's out there
seeking the attention and validation of
others on social media you want to claim
me fine you need to stop this Behavior
you know you're either Gonna Cancel your
Instagram shut it down make it private
but this is gonna stop right that's
that's your opportunity to put your foot
down and lay down the frame of the
relationship because that's really the
only time you can do it I mean you can't
do it three years in you know she's been
doing it and getting away with it and
you say you know what you need to stop
this because I saw this video with
Elliot and Rich and he said that you
know seeking validation is not a good
thing so we need to cut this off uh
that's when she's going to call you
controlling manipulative she's going to
complain to her friends and maybe even
you know bounce on that relationship so
it's it's something you have to catch
early on you have to identify early on
but women don't even know that they're
doing it because it's common today
everybody has social media but people
don't understand why they're using
social media uh she's getting DMS from
guys most of them are thirsty nerds
they're you know just just Geeks that
aren't going to crank her wheel but
the fact that she's getting thousands of
likes or comments or you're so beautiful
girl or DMS from guys over and over
again even if it's guys that she doesn't
like she has an elevated overestimation
of her value on the sexual Marketplace
and has a belief of entitlement you
don't want a woman walking around with a
big head right
um you know be beautiful take care of
yourself but if but if we're going to be
together you're mine like let's just
make that clear you're not sharing these
photographs that I should be seeing with
everybody out there to consume and at
some point she might get hit on by some
high value uh guy right and she might
have an opportunity to entertain that
you know if you permit it so
hmm you know I was thinking about your
employee about how men take pictures of
things women take pictures of themselves
I think they're going to do it
regardless uh and so what are they
taking pictures of themselves with I
think it made me what really uh made his
goal for my head was that they cut out
the picture of you in their picture you
know even my wife like me and the kids
were always like rolling our eyes
because she constantly wants to take
pictures but it's of the family it's she
and I it's with the children it's and so
I tend to see that there are a lot of
women who are married with Children and
the pictures that are on their profile
are them oftentimes it might need them
with their baby just you know trying to
guess absolutely fine validation from
other women that I have a baby but then
I ask myself well where's your husband
yeah so when it gets to the point like
you'll start to notice this so once you
see this you can't unsee it I'm sorry
I'm going to ruin this for some people
right now but you'll see this around
Valentine's Day anniversaries where
there'll be a social media post from a
guy and he'll say she's my everything
she's uh you know without her I would be
nothing blah blah blah great mother of
my kids best friend all this sort of
stuff and there's tags and posts of her
her you know looking beautiful on the
beach and some outfit or something like
that because he's trying to say
basically you know my wife's hot or you
know my wife's hot and check out my
great kids sort of thing and that's fine
but if you click through on who he's
tagging and then you see the other side
of the equation and that doesn't exist
like that's not reciprocated she's not
saying you know I've been with this man
for 10 years he's the best thing I've
ever had the best choice I ever made
it's just a picture of her still on her
profile on the beach with her
girlfriends from her girls weekend away
drinking their pinatas or whatever it is
that they're putting back uh that's
that's questionable that is to me a sign
that the clock is potentially kick
ticking down to the end of that
relationship
um so when you watch the behaviors that
are used online on social media you can
have a pretty good picture of the health
of that relationship and where it's
going
yeah 100 I really hope you guys enjoyed
that clip if you want to watch the full
length podcast you can find that over
here that clips from if you're new to
the channel make sure you hit subscribe
over here and pin down below in the top
comment you'll find a bunch of useful
links to my website my supplement line
books and a bunch of other stuff have an
amazing day peace out